[Applause]
science scientist scientist does some
horrible thing in Greece they used to
use little fourteen-year-old boys as
like flesh da [ __ ] them all back they
did back today every scientist
Pythagoras [ __ ] every little kid
right that was just what it was you had
it yeah the science exists we separate
those right we're not gonna stop using
antibiotics because Alexander Fleming
did some foul [ __ ] that meant right can
we do that with art or should we
I think distinction and they always make
does he like we need those inventions in
terms of science because it's like life
important you know if you come up with a
vaccine but you've raped a hundred
people they're still not going to throw
the vaccine because it potentially will
help and save folks I think they'll make
a distinction between that part that's
the argument they would make Rogan said
this he goes alright go go go
yeah well the question yes in the
podcast is are we saying science is less
important than art and I would say yeah
we are also I'm more important than
science is more important yeah yeah also
I think with artists when they put out
their art that's like you're like you
feel like you know them and you connect
the $2 a reflection of who they are
yeah Pythagoras theorem was in a
reflection of that existed and he
discovered it yeah
whereas art is something that actually
comes from you and you create your soul
question what about if art is so
powerful and so therapeutic did it has
almost scientific ramifications hmm
like I think there are people that feel
so good when they listen to Michael
Jackson's brother and VOC so many
emotions maybe like childhood stuff or
whatever it is it makes them feel so
[ __ ] good well some people but uh but
like can that reach the level of science
here's one difference an artist it's
like the double-edged sword if you get
famous for your creation yeah you get
worship for your creation yeah Alexander
Fleming i neva know who the [ __ ] he was
until 10 seconds ago
you don't desire or enter this business
for fame necessarily
you might get Fame with in your
community your community the people
worship you if they find out Alexander
Fleming [ __ ] kids might be like you'll
[ __ ] bit [ __ ] that dude
foul ass [ __ ] science isn't
necessarily performative whereas I art
is kind of like inherently performative
you're doing it because you want some
sort of like credit you want something
that's like want adulation but like it's
just quarter goes with the territory
it's impossible to be a singer without
singing you know I mean like the very
like its intrinsic to being a singer
that you must perform Rogan brought up
an interesting one he said the guy who
created like fertilizer you guys heard
about this one you don't maybe I think
like the same type of formula used for
the fertilizer I could be getting this
wrong was used for the gas where they
gassed the Jews oh yeah I've heard about
this something like that yeah yeah and
Zyklon a is like the fertilizer or
something dad's I can beat with it so
apparently while they're gassing Jews
he's winning the [ __ ] Nobel Peace
Prize while they're gassing Jews with
the exact same thing and understandably
so for the Nobel Peace Park bees how
many people are getting fed because now
you can actually fertilize these crops
there's way more crops out there gulp it
just it just adds your point it's the
whole Nobel Peace Prize what the whole
guy that invented the Nobel Peace Prize
you know his story
what's that literally the guy things I
Alfred Nobel or some [ __ ] okay
the guy that invented Conover yeah he
invented dynamite what he's the guy that
invented dynamite he invents his
dynamite I start getting used in like
Wars and people are blowing each other
up oh [ __ ] that is a piece someone
writes an article with they're like oh
yeah Alfred Nobel you know the the agent
of death there's some show like that
where they're like they basically gave
him the title of like oh yeah this guy
invented death and like killed all these
people and he was like oh [ __ ] I can't
be remembered as a guy that killed all
these people
yeah so he went out and started this
fund and this charity basically to be
like not we got a reward like
humanitarians hmm so he literally
invented the Nobel Peace Prize I'd have
killed out of guilt because he killed so
many people so he's like those white
people rub in black people's feet during
these protests now I guess know what
they're doing the Robin feet well you
didn't see this gotta be set up me some
of them does one of them was set up one
guy
like walking up to white women he's like
do you believe black lives matter yeah
Bethenny I was like what is happening
some of it is a setup some of is a setup
to just basically strawman the movement
but to come back to your point about the
product I feel like with art art it's
hard to measure the impact it has on
people a vaccine you take it you get
better or you prevents you from disease
we know it yeah art you can say it makes
people feel great all this stuff but
it's just like most people's problems if
they really can't see the impact they
don't believe it or they don't really
care yeah you know I can talk about
inequality all I want but watching a
black man gets snuffed in front of me
it's always gonna have more impact
because it's a visual even though this
problem is more important and it is
bigger yeah that is always gonna make
people feel more in that same token art
may have more of an impact on people's
happiness levels and fighting off
depression and all this other [ __ ] but a
vaccines always gonna hit home harder
hmm so it's just people's minds are not
apt to any kind of Cronus I yeah you can
quantify how many lives you say yeah
yeah with a vaccine you can't quantify
how many people were gonna kill
themselves until they heard this guy's
music or whatever yeah that's all like
yo totally separate note you know how
like Corona went out of business because
of Corona yeah yeah the beer I know the
beer went out of business Meyers
oh it's actually did y'all hear about
this I heard they like stop production
or something like that
I mean it's such a big beer distributor
they're probably owned by some other big
company I'll probably figure it out but
it was severely affected yeah right has
Advil not taking a hit I'm sure they
have cuz everybody blamed like I'm not
taking advil no more ever for what they
said I know what I heard is this the
initial study makes you in hey well they
said they found out [ __ ] where are
you getting these stories yo yeah
[Applause]